foreign
was a corporate Juggernaut in fact they
controlled the 80 to 85 percent of the
U.S telephone market and they were so
big and so powerful that the federal
government ordered that they be split
into seven smaller Regional companies
the this didn't really change much
though as many of these new Regional
companies it just ended up 20 forces
ended creating a duopoly known as
Verizon and atnt as a result not much
has actually changed about att's
position within the market they still
dominate a broadband internet wireless
connections and even fiber internet but
when we take a closer look at the
company's financials and stock price
it's not all that great just a few
quarters ago they had 180 billion
dollars worth of debt they haven't paid
this down a lot due to Rising interest
rates but they still have 120 billion
dollars worth of debt unfortunately it's
not just their debt that's been going
down either to accomplish this they've
had to sell off a crap ton of their
assets at the beginning of 2022 they had
577 billion dollars worth of assets but
today their total asset stands at 426
billion or 100 150 billion dollars less
and the market downturn hasn't made this
any easier for them att's Revenue has
fallen from 183 billion to 155 billion
similarly their net income has stayed
identical for 13 years now and about 20
billion likely the biggest red flag for
at T however is their stock price which
at this point peaked 23 years ago atnta
is literally at the same stock price
that it was at way back in 1995 and
that's not even accounting for inflation
since 1995 the value of the dollar
hasn't nearly halved meaning that ATT
stock is basically down at 50 percent in
the past 28 years now it should be noted
that at T does pay a strong dividend of
six percent but other than that they've
really got nothing going for them yet no
one wants to take on this company and
they remain just as powerful and
monopolistic as ever so how is atnt yet
to be disrupted
to understand why no one wants to take
on a TNT we first have to understand how
the company got so big in the first
place and this story dates all the way
back to 1875 to a man that you're
probably familiar with Alexander Graham
Bell if you're not familiar with this
guy he's the dude who invented the
telephone and like any good inventor
Graham Bella moved to monetizer's
invention by connecting the world to do
this he created a company called The
Bell Telephone Company with the two of
his buddies Thomas Watson and Gardner
green Hubbard right after he invented
the telephone the telephone was
basically an instant success and this is
not really surprising at first you
couldn't make calls from New York to
California but just being able to make
calls within NYC alone was insane you no
longer had to send a postcard or travel
30 or 45 minutes just to pass a message
instead it you could adjust telephone
the person from the comfort of your home
or office for the first few decade the
Bell company was just a conglomeration
of dozens of smaller networks spread
across the U.S but at the turn of the
century the Bell company evolved into
something much bigger thanks to a new
invention called loaded coils that could
carry signals across much longer
distances suddenly all of the smaller
networks across the U.S could start
connecting with each other to form a one
ginormous Network and Bell Telephone
would have changed their name to atnt or
American Telephone and Telegraph to
reflect this new National Focus this was
by no means an easy feat though as it
took them another 15 years to actually
make this Vision a reality but
eventually in January of 1915 Alexander
Graham Bell would be able to make a
ceremonious call from NYC to his
assistant Watson in San Francisco Graham
Bell would repeat the first words that
he ever cited through a telephone Mr
Watson come here I want you and Watson
would reply it will take me five days to
get there now as you would you guys the
crowds on both sides went absolutely
wild the mayors of the two cities would
go on to talk and even the President
Woodrow Wilson would put in a few words
we shouldn't note that this service was
insanely expensive coming in at 20.70
for the first three minutes followed by
6.35 cents for each additional minute I
mean that's expensive even in 20 23
dollars but if we adjust for inflation
we get 610 dollars for the first three
minutes followed by 200 per minute after
that obviously the average person could
not afford this but for a rich
businessmen this was an invaluable
service you were literally able to cut
down on 10 days worth of back and forth
travel just to communicate but not
everyone was so happy if at T was able
to connect California and New York that
meant that they also owned everything in
between it and Regulators weren't not
very happy with that they had let this
light for quite some time as they were
busy cracking down on Standard Oil but
after the breakup of Standard Oil in
1911 Regulators would shift their entire
Focus onto ATT
first of the government crackdowns came
in 1913 with something called the
Kingsbury commitment at the time at T
not only controlled the entire network
but they also produced the only viable
telephone fortunately for atnt the
government wasn't looking to destroy the
entire company with this settlement they
simply wanted to encourage competition
within both the network space and the
telephone space and they would soon come
to a pretty favorable settlement
consisting of three stipulations first
atnt had to allow other companies to use
their long distance Network for
commercial purposes second at T had to
spin off their telephone company into a
separate company called Western Electric
and at three at T was not allowed to
purchase any other company without the
government's approval the government
hoped that the new companies wouldn't
jump onto this opportunity but no one
did for the next 40 years and honestly
this isn't even att's fault even if at
themselves it truly encouraged
competition no one is going to compete
against them simply because it's not a
very appealing business here's the thing
as an entrepreneur during this time
period you could either produce World
War II materials jump onto the
automotive Trend or create a retail
giant or you could try to build out a
national network and take on ATT the
problem isn't that ATT is a monopoly the
problem is that the capital time and
effort required to build a network of
that skill simply isn't worth it when
there are so many better opportunities
and this is still very much True to this
day I mean would you rather build a 6G
company and try to take on a TNT or
would you rather build a social media
app and try to take on Facebook while
your odds of success are super low with
both Endeavors your odds of success in
social media are likely magnitudes
higher than your odds in
telecommunications the government
eventually came to this same realization
and they would become even more
aggressive with their crackdowns in 1949
the government would sue at T once again
and this lawsuit would be dragged on for
seven years eventually they would come
to a new settlement with three more
stipulations first ATT had to sell
Western Electric to a third party second
it ATT was barred from expanding their
business outside of connecting telephone
calls and finally at T had licensed
their patents to potential competitors
but due to all the reasons that we just
discussed no one still wanted to get
into the Telecommunications space all of
this eventually culminated into a
boiling point in 1982 when Regulators
ordered that atnt be split up into seven
different companies and seems like the
government was pretty confident in this
move in fact they were so confident that
they would even remove the stipulations
of the 1956 agreement meaning that the
new smaller companies could expand and
dim new lines of business ironically
though this this ended up backfiring big
time as this simply allowed ATT to
expand into broadband internet and
Wireless Communications the two sectors
that have allowed them to survive
through all of this the one thing that
becomes extraordinarily clear is that
you can't kill monopolies simply using
regulation or even breakups the only way
to kill monopolies is through
revolutionary Innovation take standard
oil for example they were literally
broken up over a hundred years ago yet
there's still a top 10 company worth 450
billion dollars in the form of Exxon the
reason for this is that people's demand
for oil never changed in fact it only
went up the same thing could be said
about ATT for much of the 1900s the
Government tried everything they could
to stop at T other than straight up
shutting down the company but none of
this addressed the insatiable demand for
communications something that did
address this demand however was the
internet and cell phones but somehow the
government managed to break up atnt at
the perfect time for them to switch to
supporting the internet and cell phones
if the government had and done that at T
would have gotten destroyed given that
landline popularity has plummeted from
80 to 29 within the past 14 years but
instead it at T has been able to build a
new life with new sectors at this point
even Money Can't disrupt ATT and the
best example of this is Google's attempt
to take on ATT about 10 years ago Google
would tried to take on their broadband
internet Market by introducing it Google
Fiber at that time most Broadband
connections offered 10 maybe 20 Mbps per
second Max meanwhile Google was willing
to offer 1 000 Mbps or 1 gbps for
relatively affordable prices
first Google expanded to several cities
very quickly but it didn't take them
long to realize that they had bitten off
more than they could chew you see it as
soon as Google started introducing fiber
ATT hit back harder than they could ever
imagine at T turned around and spent 140
billion dollars on a nationwide rollout
of fiber and today they offer even
better speeds than Google coming in at
up to 5 gigabits per second now if
Google really wanted it they could go
all in on fiber and try to take on a TNT
but for what given that they would have
to build from scratch it would cost them
200 or 250 billion dollars even if a
bunch of people adopted this service and
Google Fiber grew to be as large as the
entire company of atnt it would still
just be a 130 billion dollar business
even if it became a 200 or 300 billion
dollar business that simply isn't worth
it when you're investing 200 to 250
billion dollars you're expecting it
trillions in return not hundreds of
billions not to mention it it's not even
an easy to manage simple business either
you literally have to deal with managing
hundreds of billions of dollars worth of
infrastructure just to make 10 margins
Google had a very similar realization
with their Wireless project Google fi as
well and if a company as powerful and as
rich as Google can take on a TNT no one
can
in the end ATT is one of those super
weird businesses that's worth owning it
if it already exists but not worth
building at this point the only way that
this company gets taken down it is if
another Communications Revolution comes
around and the company doesn't pivot now
of course maybe Verizon can slowly chip
away at their market share and slowly
drive them to unprofitability but that
doesn't really mean much given that rise
in it is also a product of the original
ATT with all of that being said though
we do have to give ATT prompts unlike
the leading tech companies that are
constantly trying to grow and reach the
next magnitude ATT has been very
comfortable with where they are they
know their Lane and they know it very
well and they don't care about exploring
other lanes of course they have made
some growth moves in the past like
buying a DirecTV but for the most part
they just stick to what they're good at
and they pay out as high dividends as
they can
that's what they've been doing for the
past 140 years and that's what they're
gonna do moving forward and ain't no one
gonna do anything about it but that's
just what I think are you happy with
your internet provider comment that down
below also drop a like if you wish more
companies stopped chasing it endless
growth and of course consider checking
out our Discord Community suggest for
the video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered
but until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys the next one